こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
えーー　動画のタイトルとサムネイルを見れば分かると思うんだけどもぉ
（サッ）新しい部屋です！（パチパチ）
つっても引っ越しした訳じゃないんですけどね
引っ越ししたわけじゃないんですけども
あのーー
ちょっと最近ですね
というかこの先ですね 　どっちかというと
ま、今、静岡に住んでるんですけども
たぶんなんですけど
来月からめちゃくちゃ忙しくなっちゃて
ひょっとしたらじゃなくて　多分ほぼ確定です
もう確定で！（断言）
静岡にほぼ帰れなくなっちゃうわけです僕が
静岡に帰れなくなっちゃうんで
そもそも何で静岡に帰るかっていうと
やっぱ静岡でしか撮れない動画とか
静岡にパソコンもあの、でかいやつね
スペックの良いパソコンとかもあるし
で、撮影機材
撮影に必要なものとか
人出とか
まさきとか
他の友達とか
いろんなものが全部静岡にあるんで
僕が動画を撮りたいって言ったら
もう静岡に帰るしかないんですよ
ところがどっこい！
来月ですね８月から実は
めちゃめちゃ忙しくなってしまいまして
とりあえずはです
とりあえずは
８月からしばらくの間は
東京を拠点に活動しようと思っております
であの
東京に部屋借りてるじゃないですか、泊まる用の
泊まる用の部屋借りてるんですけども
そこもやっぱりなんやかんやアパートで
やっぱり他の人も住んでいるわけなんで
やっぱりこうなんか声とか大声出しちゃうと迷惑掛かっちゃうんで
正直結構撮りづらいとこあるんですよ
撮れるんですけど撮れるですけども
撮りづらいところがあるんで
だいたい片道２時間掛かるんですよ
僕ん家から駅まで
行って20分でくらいで
で新幹線乗って1時間
でそっから
事務所まで移動したりすると
だいたい2時間くらい掛かっちゃって
往復で4時間掛かるわけですよ
それももったいないし
東京の家で静かにぼそぼそと動画撮ってても
こう思ったようにいかないし
それで東京で動画撮りたくなかったんです
て、なったときに！
動画用の部屋を、準備するしかないと
そういうわけなんで
僕はもうこのもう動画を撮影するためだけの
youtubeの事なんでもするためだけの部屋を
ゲットしました
なんかトークって落ち着かないな
ちょっとこの部屋がどんな感じなのかちょっと皆さんに紹介できればいいなと思っております
完全にもう僕のための部屋なんで
もうなんでもしていいんすよ
殴るのはやめとこ
まずは
です
まあ普段結構力抑えてるんですけど
僕そもそも暴れる系のyoutuberなんで
暴れたいんですよ
なんでこの部屋は
もう僕がどれだけ暴れてもいいように
防音機能がばっちりなんです
試してみましょう
わああああああああああああ！！！！
すいません
男）なにしてん
すいませんでした
男）気をつけてな
すみません
男）うん
(キラーン音)
次いきましょう
はい、続いてはちょっと部屋の中を
見ていきましょう
まあそんなに大きくはないんですけども
十分なサイズがあります
で照明がかっこいんすよ
このおしゃれをきどる照明感
そしてやっぱ棚がねおしゃれなんすよね
まだなんもないんですけど
動画撮るようにソファと机と
棚だけが置いてあります
凄いっしょ
これで暗くできるし
暖色と寒色でね
色が変わるんですよ
今多分暖色で
これ押すと
ほら青色に青色、青色になる青色
でこれを押すと
暖色、あったかい色
寒い色
あっ
さむ
あっさむあっ
ったかい
色っていう感じにね
やべ、やった
もう部屋の照明の感じすらも変えられるっていう
もう素晴らしいお部屋になっております
はいというわけで新しい部屋を見ていったと思うんですけども
いかがだったでしょうか
もうねほんと静岡にいたいんですよ
静岡だと自然もきれいだし
外の撮影も楽だし
なんせ僕は
静岡が好きです
なんですけども、まちょっとねしばらく本当に東京でまじで忙しいので
もう静岡東京の行き来をしてると
もう動画どころじゃないみたいな
少しでも時間を節約して
もったいない時間をなるべく無くして
まあyoutubeの動画を少しでもたくさん撮れるように
ちょっと頑張っていきたいと思いますので
多分まだすぐにはここに移動しないと思います
8月辺りかな8月ぐらいからここに移動すると思うんで
まあとりあえず東京にこうゆう部屋があるよっていう
今日はお話しでございました
忙しくなくなったら一回静岡に戻ると思うんで
そこは安心してください
ちょっと今いろいろ準備して、いろいろ僕自身も変わろうと思ってるんで
ちょっとバタバタしていますが、また
またはじめしゃちょーをよろしくお願いします
じゃあな
ばいばい
ENDING♪